when we're in Canton watching all the
speeches the the fantasy footballers
podcast is I got a live show already
sold out
Largo right here in Los Angeles they've
got a live tour that's ending in their
hometown of Phoenix Arizona on August
24th at the Crescent Ballroom tickets
are on sale now from the highly part is
we figured since we talked fantasy with
Mike del two foes golf story last hour
we might as well continue the subject
with fantasy football co-host of the
fantasy footballers podcast good to see
Mike Wright and Jason Moore how are you
guys that's fantastic to be here yeah
doing great sitting in the Rich Eisen
chair yeah
well that actually gasps yes chair I
mean yeah I mean you know you just
appeared right you're trying to take my
seat right humble years but I understand
you got a hundred million downloads but
I mean you know let's just baby steps it
is just baby steps but no super happy to
be I'm glad that you guys are here
Andy Holloway is gonna join us later on
on our on our isin overtime segment how
did you guys get started how did this
all gets through the the podcasts really
started Andy and I yeah we made a
podcast just for our league for our
fantasy football league in our office
where once a week on lunch what office
we all work together at a game studio in
Scottsdale Arizona okay and fantasy
football was the passion besides making
the games yes and we made a podcast for
12 people to listen to where we just
talked to garbage is so great it was it
was as a listener at that point one of
the 10 listeners yes it was so great
they were just mocking us and you know I
would make trades in the league just to
get on the show of like I want to be the
trade of source Rex
yes this week and then you know so fun
and and insightful I think they decided
we can turn this outward and then they
brought me on and off you go
yeah off you cuz it's so difficult I
mean I remember when the NFL Network
started how could we get fantasy
football involved in our broadcast and
it's just so difficult because it's kind
of we talk about it all the time Chris
and I it's like poker like everybody's
got a bad beat everybody's been in a
poker hand everybody's had a problem
with fantasy football everyone's gotten
screwed everyone's won or something for
not everyone I mean we did last year but
not everyone so how do you guys make it
entertaining like what is your challenge
every single week to figure this thing
out you know the the the combination of
entertaining and having bad beats yes is
really important to us because we we do
an entertaining show like we don't you
know there's some shows you can listen
to
they dig deep they do all the analysis
I'm like you know you can choose between
zzzquil or that show to like I'll do a
lot of go to bed right and so we want to
entertain people but the problem is when
you're entertaining people think you
don't know what you're talking about
right if you have a bad beat and you
make a bad prediction there are they
don't know what they're talking about
thankfully we you know we've we're
tracked by fantasy prose and we're we're
very I don't want to be too 2d here to
be just happy but you know we've we've
been in the top ten for you know most of
the last several years out of 150 so it
gives us the optin 110 most accurate
analysts so it gives us the ability to
just have fun but how does one measure
accuracy that you that you've nailed
what what did you nail so you rank every
single player every single week and you
know kind of they're all compared
there's a scoring system okay that
they've developed and so you know we've
been in that for several years but it
and your top ten
we have been tough to in multiple times
yeah all right so then let's ask him the
poll question right off the bat right
here Chris broccoli we've been asking
this poll questions all day brought to
you by our friends at route car for the
moment when it comes to selling or
trading in your car you know make good
choices and with true car you've got a
star on your roster so when you're ready
to sell or trade in your car check out
true car to cash off are not available
in all areas go for it Chris Brockman
which wide receiver guys do you take
first in fantasy this year Michael
Thomas Odell Julio Jones DeAndre Hopkins
I'll take your PPR answer first you
don't even have the right so no you
don't came when that is Davante Adams
but if I'm gonna answer the poll yes
Hopkins yeah but I would agree with my
co-host here that Davante Adams has the
safest floor and the highest ceiling I
mean you've got a quarterback in Aaron
Rodgers that's you know several years in
a row was averaging 40 touchdowns a
season he's the clear number one Jordy
Nelson back the day was
you often the number one wide receiver
and yeah I think Davante Adams sky's
limit even if it's standard not PPR Oh
even more so for standard because he
doesn't get the reception total that
that Adams or that uh that Hopkins is
gonna see but right
he's just it's so consistent and that's
the difference where even if Adams
finishes at two or three yes it's not
just the end of the season ranking
that's important for these wide
receivers how are they doing on a
week-to-week basis because there's some
guys the end of the year they'll jump
into the top ten but forty percent of
the time you were bummed out that you
started them so I'm in a league let's
say I'm in a league ten teams and it's a
snake draft and I'm sitting there five
or six right so I know people are gonna
throw their lot in with a bunch of
running backs
somebody might even take my homes
because they're no don't do that
we'll get to that in a second I'm just
throwing that all out there and every
wide receivers available I'm going
Davante Adams and that's what you
suggest every single Rich Eisen show
listener and viewer to do yes well I
mean I would probably go David Johnson
there or still a running back over if
you're at five or six yes
I'm probably not taking a wide receiver
until a little bit later but the first
wide receiver off the board I would be
taking Devon to Adam first overall is
sake one uh for me it's Christian
McCaffrey for me after he reports at Z
but you know right now a tiebreaker is
sake one's great option hmm it looks by
the way you you guys are looking at me
like I'm crazy for throwing this out
there so Christian McCaffrey in year
three for you is the number one overall
draft choice and a fantasy draft anybody
who's listening in the sound of my voice
watching has a first overall pick in a
draft they are going they based on you
Mike right you Jason more of the
footballers podcast
well I McCaffrey and he's Zeke okay
though you're saying McCaffrey yes and
you say Zeke I say ZK whatever he
reports listen but what if he reports
you know last week of September and you
you have your draft and in early August
yeah what happens that if you're
drafting before there's clarity there
that situation there's no reason to take
Zeke
over the other big three which would be
say Kwan Christian McCaffrey now
Camero seeks not gonna turn into left
Bell this year I mean that I can't
imagine that well he can because Zeek
once Amory Cooper came Zeke was on pace
for almost the same recording out the
whole year that's what I mean oh yeah
that's what I'm saying he's not rich
that's why I'm saying that you know it's
still somewhat safe if he hasn't
reported in late August your fantasy
league is in late August so many people
last year just said screw it I'm taking
love Belle anyway right and they many of
them finished in last place in their
fantasy leagues yeah love bill was a
that was a rough situation last year
especially when reports from him and his
camper he's gonna show up and play and
not so much nip but the thing was eek
like if he's if he's showing up late yes
I mean we want we want his body getting
acclimated to all those hits that he's
going to take so like you said when you
were at the beginning of the first round
we've we've seen running backs come in
late to training camp and then they get
that hamstring early what's your
philosophy on Todd Gurley oh goodness
it's not it's not good I have a really
hard time pulling the trigger on girly
you know what they're saying is great
but what they've done what the Rams have
done you look at their moves mmm
obviously saw his utilization in the
Super Bowl game once he was back in the
playoffs but then they trade up they
draft another running back they match
the tender given you know to the Mart
around yet to brown and so it's one of
those things where they can say he's
still their guy but every move they've
made follow the money we say you know
that's where you can actually see what a
team believes and cut through the fluff
and the money says they are worried
about Todd Gurley so I'm worried if
you're talking about into the first
round yes if he drops into the second I
still think he can be productive with an
Alvin Kamara type of workload but I'm
not taking them in the first Jason more
Mike Wright co-hosts of fantasy
footballers podcast Andy Holloway who's
the third man and he's going to join us
later on for our aizen overtime that's
available only on on the app your
philosophy on drafting quarterbacks I
just threw out there my home it was just
lights out I mean and you get four
points for every touchdown this is the
format obviously
the league that I'm in you get bonus
five points for 300 yards another five
for 400 yards I mean why wouldn't I want
to take him in the middle of a first
round so the bonus points does skew
things a little bit but the thing is the
reason why Patrick mahomes were part of
it I mean 50 touchdowns is sensational
but he was a late round pick or he was
grabbed off of the waiver wire that's
why he helped so many teens and and I
assume in your league you're playing one
quarterback yes so by the way I refuse
to play in a league that's got more than
one goal oh there's not happy with you
right now why they why here's the reason
please because these please well what do
we what are we doing here you know the
reason backs yes the reason is ya
quarterback as I think you'd agree yeah
the most important position in football
right it's not in fantasy football and
that's what people want to get to is
where there's the market is saturated
with quarterbacks we're gonna put up
excellent weeks you only like you can
get a quarterback so lates like Jared
Goff where Jared Goff was second in the
league in 20-yard completions only
behind mahomes and people have they've
written him off you can get him in
double digit rounds sometimes off the
waiver wire and he's gonna put up
comparable numbers to patrick mahomes
meanwhile cuz you only got to start one
of them meanwhile you've got to start
multiple running backs multiple wide
receivers yeah because that's the way
it's done in the National Football
League
exactly but you've got to take those
guys early and if you're if you're
taking Patrick mahomes in the second or
the third round you are making a huge
sacrifice of your draft equity in in a
running back or a wide receiver that's
gonna be fantastic but the wide
receivers in the third round they're
it's littered with incredible talent and
the difference that if you're taking
mahomes there he has to throw 50
touchdowns he has to do that to be to
separate himself or separate himself
from the other quarterbacks and 50
touchdowns that's only been done three
times so if we're talking about homes
then then your philosophy is don't take
a quarterback until what round 10 we get
a lot of people that you know I know
it's something I team how many teams are
in this
well yeah usually twelve so don't take
to round ten so I mean look I'm a big
believer in he brought up golf and Cam
Newton they're going like round nine I'm
willing to pull the trigger there but
the reality is there's there's probably
twenty quarterbacks that are good for
fantasy Josh Allen Lamar Jackson those
guys are gonna be just fine they're done
drafted in a lot of these leagues you
only start 12 but with the depth and the
injuries and the bye weeks and
everything through a season yeah at
running back and wide receiver you need
as many as you can get so I just keep
stockpiling all of those great ones if
I'm in a league where people are taking
quarterback early great all it means is
my running backs and wide receivers I'm
getting in later rounds are better cuz
everyone took a quarterback early then I
grabbed Cam Newton or Jared Goff in the
10th round and my overall team is much
better than your overall team even
though you have a better quarterback
it's the easiest position and fantasy to
figure out who's gonna have or whose
high probability they're gonna have a
good game yes and you can grab these
guys off the waiver wire where I mean
every year when you look back there's
always over 40 quarterbacks who put up a
top 12 week and like the only 32 teams
that's a spasm quarterbacks come in and
if you see that they're against the 28th
ranked defense against the pass yeah and
they're out home fire them up because
he's gonna give you 250 yards and two
touchdowns and that's that's what you
need I'm sitting there round 1112 and I
got Lamar Jackson I got Kyle Amari who
do I take it's hard take that out take
two take that out I know you already
threw David Johnson to me and I love him
but I have no earthly idea what to
expect out of him and there's no way if
I've got a fourth or fifth overall
selection I'm just gonna go yeah I'll go
with the guy that had a great year with
Ariens a couple years ago and I have no
idea what's going on but take the
Cardinals fandom out of the equation
the Phoenix hometown out of the equation
Mauri Lamar Jackson what do you what do
you think it has to be Kyle Emery
because they're both electric on the
ground and running is such a cheat code
for fantasy quarterbacks but they are
vastly different through the air and
you've got the new Kliff Kingsbury
system coming in where you're going from
last year there's on a Cardinals load up
the middle you have running up
over middle you know the fewest points
per game what'd you think of their
offense last year I can't tell the
middle so I'm sorry I mean interrupt no
no it's just one of the things where
it's like you've you've got David
Johnson right you're you're worried
about him he disappointed last year cuz
he was one of the top three picks and
fantasy but he still was running backed
in but when it comes to the the Arizona
Cardinals offense going from one of the
slowest pace of play teams to what we
can presume based on you know Kliff
Kingsbury coming in is gonna be one of
the fastest pace of play and you've got
an accurate Kyler Murray I think that
Kyler Murray is a much better passer
than Lamar Jackson is right now even
even though he's a rookie so I'm gonna
take the guy who's a true dual threat
versus Lamar Jackson that I think is
going to get the majority of his points
just rushing well I should say we have
Lamar Jackson on tomorrow show I think
he's gonna have a better year throwing I
do I just think he's a kid who's got a
huge arm last year they threw him in in
the middle of the season they totally
remade their offense to suit what he
could do at that moment I'd be stunned I
mean they jollywood Brown just I think
God I mean come on this guy's gonna take
the top off the defense and they got
Ingram and Gus Edwards coming down hill
to hit you to maybe to try and make you
think that they have the football still
I think he's gonna have some easy
pickings with all those tight ends - I
like it they're gonna give him some easy
throws and he's gonna sometimes just
rear back and throw it I I mean don't
get me wrong I love Lamar Jackson but
your organist and he's not as good a
thrower as connemara correct and that's
not an indictment on Lamar Jackson so
much as an endorsement Ison calimary
very good very good
Mike Wright Jason Moore here of the
fantasy footballers podcast where all
podcasts are available the fantasy
football is calm as well where you can
get the ultimate draft kit from you and
the neat part about it is yes that parts
of the proceeds go to st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital which I
know is near and dear to you guys it is
to me how'd you get fixed up with st.
Jude so it was I mean we had talked
about it where we're last year we
partnered with crucial catch
it´ll gave some proceeds to them from
the draft kit sales and
we just you know we were looking around
would what charity really speaks to our
heart and we're all fathers of three
kids and st. Jude just it it was I mean
perfect match for us yeah we we spent
time all of us have spent time in a
Children's Hospital you know my best
friend growing up Brittany she died
young of a serious disease and I spent a
lot of time there and so I it's one of
those where is not a lie to say like it
really did speak to us we sought out
working with st. Jude because you know
we believe in what they're doing as
fathers and as people who've experienced
that side it's just it's just amazing
yeah yeah yeah there but for the grace
of God go any of us with children and
st. Jude depends all it's solely based
on donations to st. Jude where nobody
sees a bill they don't see a bill for
transportation I don't see a bill for
any of you for housing don't see a bill
for any medical cost don't see a bill
for anything all the folks that go to
st. you just focus on the kid and the
kid getting better and I think it you
chose wisely thank you to have portions
of the proceeds of your ultimate draft
kit at the fantasy footballers com go to
st. Jude Children's Research Hospital
before I let you go any of the league's
that you're in last place did they
there's the last place individual yes
yeah we do we have we developed a wheel
of water app where you can make bets
water bets we do it on our show it's
just as free yep in the Bywater it means
you find a very embarrassing way to
throw water on someone like for example
is the English Channel
someone must lay upon the floor or the
street pretend they're swimming and then
you you dump water on them it sounds
childish but it is very sad no I'm just
wondering if there's any respectful way
to throw water on somebody well the
original says disrespectful on its face
well when you're comparing just a splash
to the face okay
between that and what we call wearing it
in their pocket pockets here more
disrespectful but the nice thing is when
we get our lead together the 11 owners
that did not finish last all spin the
wheel and douse the drafter who then
drafts soaking wet Oh
in Arizona where we crank the AC down to
1600 it's gnarly unpleasant
we love water app so you just press it
and it goes up with the any of them yeah
more most disrespectful yes methods of
water thrown delivery that's how it
works okay very good
@ff hit man yes sir that would be you
sir a fantasy football hit man at Jason
FFL and at Andy Holloway is gonna join
us in the Rich Eisen show isin overtime
segment where I'm gonna get from you
guys Dark Horse's we you know it just
got to hurt we got Trevor Davis out of
Bakhtiari I thought he might say Jai
Kumar Oh buddy whatsoever day look at
you you're just dropping names that
people need to go look up just to make
you look smart
that just happened you got me there he
go busted
okay so stick around for isin overtime
look all right we're gonna write we
having a hell of a show tomorrow I mean
I could not be more excited about
tomorrow's show wait do you hear who is
in studio that's coming up next right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app